are modern people's brains broken in
your
opinion broken is a is a big word um and
I definitely can identify with being
broken with my uh traumatic brain injury
when I was a child and my learning
difficulties and people teasing me
calling me broken and I feel like our
minds are under assault for sure you
know with uh technology I don't think
necessarily technology is is the reason
but certainly technology can amplify the
issues distraction and forgetfulness and
this kind of overload information
anxiety and it's an interesting world
you know the amount of information is
doubling at dising speeds but feel like
uh we're not really prepared I don't
know a lot of people who aren't
struggling right now with forgetfulness
or distraction maintaining their
concentration feels like taking a sip of
water out of a fire hose nowadays just
to kind of catch up and keep up yeah how
you how you doing with this uh data delu
it's interesting because obviously I I
consume so much for the podcast you know
prep for the guests and other reading
and and then my own reading and then the
useless consumption of everything from
social media to YouTube when I'm
watching when I'm trying to eat my lunch
and stuff it's a mix bag because there
are so many amazing insights that I
really value and yet coming along for
the ride is this kind of
ambient distraction almost like this
habituating ADHD thing that comes in
where I just find myself task switching
even though I don't need to uh so you
know from you've spent forever studying
the brain both for yourself and from a
professional perspective yeah how many
of the problems that people are dealing
with when it comes to focus and
attention are an inbuilt endemic part of
being a human and how many do you think
are novel and can be laid at the feet of
the modern
world well think things are were
definitely simpler for our brains as
Hunter and gatherers right we're we want
to we want to be able to survive and
that that's a big prerogative we want to
be able to reproduce we want to be able
to know where all the the fresh water is
and the enemy tribe and the and you know
where the fertile soil is nowadays
though every day I feel like people are
just really they're sprinting just to
catch up right new technology new people
new ideas fast changes endless updates
you it's happening in our careers in
school and business industry and
literally every every person's daily
life and so people feel a little
overwhelmed by the growing um like the
data clutter you stressed out by all the
knowledge that you must absorb and
process and read and and recall you know
the the nature of my work is really how
do you stay on top and and deal with all
that yeah I've I've noticed uh executive
function so your ability to kind of
project manage yourself and and what
what's happening is
increasingly like the Vanguard of my
life right you know it really is it's
like the it's the absolute front lines
of what's going on because there is so
much different inputs and so many
different things to do and oh I could go
done that rabbit hole and I could have
this conversation with this person and
maybe I'll do this thing and um there
was a point probably like at June of
2011 where the amount of information
that people wanted and the amount of
information that was available a
roundabout balanced and for almost all
of human history there was less and then
it got to I don't know at some point in
the last sort of 50 years it it hit
equilibrium and then very quickly it
just blasted straight through so
previously the uh smart thinker was
somebody who was able to scout for
information and actually find
information whereas now the most
important tool I think is someone who's
able to discern appropriately and
they're able to triage and they're able
to uh titrate whatever it is is that's
needed you know what I mean yeah it's
definitely a filtering issue and a prior
prioritizing issue also as well I mean
we have unfeathered access to the
world's information they say that with
our phones we have more access to
information than President Clinton did
when he was in office and we just
carrying it around with us and I don't
know if the human brain really evolved
to to deal with that Onslaught with all
the context switching of social media uh
with all the Rings and pings and dings
and app notifications all the social
media alerts uh it's uh it's it's a it's
a different animal now nowadays and I
think more than ever we need to really
invest in our brains to upgrade our
brains we we hear about upgrading our
technology all the time you get the
newest iPhone and upgrade your apps and
your software your television whatever
but um not a to talk about upgrading the
most important technology that has
created all the technology you know
which is which is the brain and so that
that that's the nature I feel like a lot
of people also don't know a lot enough
about their brain it's not really taught
in school there's no owner manual it's
not not really user friendly but it
controls everything I think we're we
live in the Millennium of the mind I
don't think any of the listeners solely
it's not like it was hundreds of years
ago where it was
really our our value in society was our
brute strength today it's our brain
strength right it's not our muscle power
as much as it is our our mind power our
ability to learn to unlearn to to
relearn also um yeah I was doing a
program at I just did a Google talks and
I remember when I first started doing
trainings at Google helping with mental
Fitness there was this quote from Eric
Schmidt who was then chairman and uh
said the amount of information I'm
paraphrasing the amount of information
that's been created through the dawn of
humanity to the year
2003 which was only what two decades ago
how long does it take to create that
amount of information today you know and
the answer was like 48 hours I mean
we're drowning in it you think about all
the the podcasts right and the social
media YouTube there's just so much
information but how we learn it and read
it understand it you know that hasn't
changed a whole lot you know we live in
an age of autonomous electric cars
spaceships that are going to Mars but
our vehicle choice in comparison when it
comes to our own personal learning is
more like a horse and horse and buggy so
I I feel like we could really you know
do well by upgrading some of these uh
these mindset in these methods what do
you wish more people knew about how the
brain works you know functionally like
there's there's you know interesting
stuff to do with the pituitary and the
hypothalamus and blah blah but when it
comes to the nuts and bolts of how
people use their brain and what they
want it to do if you were to give a
bunch of headlines you had a bunch of
billboards out there that you could
maybe put put some things on to remind
people what what would be the lessons
that you wish people knew about the
thermodynamics of their own mind so
stress response probably is is up there
I don't know if it' be the top one but
it's invisible for a lot of people
because we're so used to it it's like a
fish in water not recognizing the water
because it's always present we know that
chronic sh uh stress could potentially
shrink the human brain puts you in fight
or flight you know the cortisol the
adrenaline and I feel like it you're in
your it keeps you in your survival brain
and maybe you're held hostage from your
executive functioning from your ability
to solve problems uh from your own
creativity you know chronic stress will
strength the brain chronic fear and we
live in a society with marketing and
media where it's perpetual fear
and uh you know if it bleeds it leads
and it's very intelligent it's working
exactly how it's designed to work but I
think that there's also this the analogy
is like there's this algorithm just like
there's an algorithm with social media
whatever you engage with you see more of
right you you engage in all the
entrepreneurs stuff or the cat videos
you like and share and comment you get
more of it in your news feed but I feel
like if we're whatever we engage with
our with our mind also if we're looking
at what's threatening and scary and what
could harm us uh like in the news then
you know whatever we engage with we tend
to see more of it all the time and
chronic fear will actually suppress your
your immune system which is is a big
issue nowadays because you can't turn on
you can't go on social media or the news
without seeing something that's you know
life-threatening and it feels like it's
happening local even if it haveing more
more more Global whole area of science
called psychon neuroimmunology you know
it's where we're more susceptible to
colds the flu the viruses so I think
having even just coping mechanisms to
deal with stress you know some people do
body work some people get uh do do U
mindfulness training or or meditation or
they use a float tank or any of these
biohacks but I feel like we're under a
lot of undue stress and that locks up
our nervous system and you know it's
it's hard to learn if you're if you're
wired for survival and you're in that's
your your mindset you're not in it that
you your those creative juices aren't
aren't flowing right and I feel like
we're not using all that potentiality
that that our mind has I've got a
interesting story about this so I'm
currently doing my first live shows uh
where stepping out on stage it's 90
minutes of solo talking all of the
events were sold out in under 60 Minutes
2,000 people across the U the UK and
Ireland and then we're doing 1500 people
in Dubai and then I've got a US and
Canada to com up with James Smith at the
end of the year
anyway I know the stuff that I'm talking
about right I know this stuff implicitly
I came up with the ideas it's all Bro
Science bro philosophy stuff that that
I've come up with right and it's stories
from where I've been and who I've spoken
to and all the rest of it and the first
time that I did the show I was so
nervous backstage that when I went out
it was like somebody had just put
blinkers on my mind and I'm trying to
access the stories that literally I
created right I made these things myself
and somehow I can't access the things
that I had now thankfully I had a
comfort Monitor and it could you know
keep on prompting me but without that if
you just said okay and now talk to me
about the lonely chapter and talk to me
about the tall girl problem and talk to
me about blah blah blah I I just didn't
have access to it and that is a very
acute version of this right everyone
knows everyone knows you you you the
nerves kick in something happens and you
go my performance isn't where it was
supposed to be Morgan housel taught me
about this guy uh archal archal somebody
somebody uh let me check my notes from
yesterday what was the [__] guy's
name this dude this dude in the uh 1900s
early 1900s archal Hill um he studied
how quickly people could run and he was
able to predict based on V2 Max and lact
de threshold and all this stuff he could
predict how quickly they would do a mile
or whatever distance around a track
unbelievably accurately but it had
basically zero predictive power when it
came to competition races and this was
highly criticized it's like hang on a
second I thought you've got this formula
and it only works in one context well
yeah because when you take them out of
that context and into a competition all
bets are off all rules are out of the
window it's a different predisposition
their adrenaline their cortisol all of
this the amount of sleep that they had
last night you told me this story about
uh the greatest downhill skier of of
female downhill skier ever this lady and
um maybe she was Canadian and she would
throw up before every single race that
she did wow wow an elite athlete right
and you've optimized your hydration and
think about your sleep and just before
you step out on stage you throw up and
you go okay like all all of that stuff
was totally out but look at what she
does in training in training she doesn't
throw up so I just think yeah the um the
ability for fear stress overwhelm
especially acutely to just completely
wreck our performance
is it's it's wild and I've felt that
firsthand and I'm now worked out for me
a process that I can go through before a
live show so that I don't feel like that
um but without that tool I was just at
the mercy of the Winds of my fear and
stress and and I think a lot of
listeners have their stages right you
know if you're if you're on stage and
you switch context there's that phrase
in that content is King right or content
is Queen but if content is is King then
I think context is is the Kingdom right
and all all learning and performance is
context dependent without without a
doubt and it's also State dependent you
know practicing in the environment that
you need to be able to perform in those
kind of conditions and even if it's not
the external environment the internal
environment is mirroring or you're using
at the power of your imagination to be
able to to replicate that and and
rehearse on on a regular yeah I my
biggest challenge besides learning
growing up was public speaking by far I
mean this wasn't you really chose the
right career didn't you as expert in
learning who often does public speaking
this is this is this is my lot in life
for sure it's um but it's it's a
testament that and I'm I'm sure this
resonates with a lot of listeners that
that with challenge comes change right
with our struggles they can become
strengths uh because I had my learning
difficulties and I was labeled broken I
I would be terrified of public speaking
because I just never knew the answer it
took me three years longer to learn how
to read so it's very embarrassing I
think that's those circles where those
reading circles I think a lot of Fear
public speaking came from that right
where you pass around the book and you
had to read out loud a paragraph or a
page and that was like the worst for me
I mean even just thinking about it my
stomach like get I get nauseous I mean I
can't tell you how many times in I could
relate to these performers where they're
just throwing up and vomiting and
because I was in the nurse's office all
the time and it was all self-inflicted
for sure I mean part of it might have
been strategic to get out of class so I
I wanted to be called on and I wouldn't
have to give that book report in front
of the class but that it was terrifying
I never knew the answer my my superpower
back in school was being invisible I
mean it was it was shrinking down I mean
even my physiology I was always like you
know uh collapsing so I would take up
less space in the world so I wouldn't be
noticed and you know at that time I
didn't really want to be seen I mean
probably I did right I mean everyone
wants to be seen they want to be
understood they want to be heard but you
know coping mechanism was just avoidance
it was just it was just hard and so yeah
you're right life has a sense of humor
because those are my challenges now all
I do is public speak on this thing
called learning um but you know I think
adversity can be an advantage I I don't
know one strong person that had an easy
life right and um so I feel like you
know certain things come into our lives
just like the hero's journey I open
Limitless expanded with Joseph
Campbell's like the stages of the heroes
Journey because I want people to feel
like that they are the hero they are the
uh the Dorothy or the luk Skywalker if
they if you were you know taking on the
uh the big bad witches or the the the
the Death Star those kind of things
finding a mentor and coming back and
returning with some some gems some gold
and that they could share with the rest
of the world what do you think are the
biggest lies of learning goodness yeah a
lie for me I use a lot of acronyms
because they're shortcuts for you know
these pneumonics we used back in school
like homes for the great lakes here on
Ontario Michigan Aries Superior uh there
were like these mental shortcuts for so
for lies for me is a limited idea
entertained I feel like it's you know Li
that's what lie is you know we talk
about you know various things in the
section of mindset that could hold us
back because if you want to achieve
something a lot of people want to go
right to the methods and I'm definitely
guilty of that but I think so many
people including a lot of your listeners
they know what to do but they're not
always doing what they know and if they
sabotage it's usually a mindset issue
because they're buying into these lies
like one of them could be Geniuses born
right and it's been my experience the
past 30 years of just coaching is that
genius while there's certain traits
certainly if you if you're if you if
you're born with a certain height or or
you know certain attributes you
certainly have an advantage in in in
today's uh Marketplace and in the world
um in competitions but also I think
genius could certainly be built right I
I think when somebody exhibits something
that there's that looks like magic to
the rest of the world it there's a
method behind it you know and I think
part of Genius is pattern recognition
you know seeing the invisible that makes
this possible and for me it's always a
combination of mindset motivation
methods to kind of create this this
momentum in your life by kind of
unlimiting these areas and um yeah so
some of one of them would be genius is
born as as opposed to being built I I
talk about this this this story um as we
learn through stories and you're an
amazing Storyteller you know always
always listen watching your YouTube and
and and just really observing at a meta
level your style but there there was
this one where um there was this King
and uh and they had this performer and
uh this performer was doing a you know
was basically
it had magic right and the the counselor
was like Hey and this is genius is born
it is not born it's built and the King
was really upset by that because the
king really wanted to buy in that you
know people are born with genius you
know with this amazing talent and so to
punish the counselor he put him in the
basement of the uh the kingdom and and
just to add salt to the wound he gave
them like two little piglets to to live
with right like be be with your own kind
kind of thing and while this counselor
was there he would take the piglets and
hold them underneath his arms and and
then run up and down the stairs you know
you know every single day multiple times
a day and one day the king you know
weeks and weeks weeks maybe months later
thinks about the the counselor and says
hey bring the counselor you know back to
my throne room I want to you know see
how he's doing and he comes and he's
he's he's jacked I mean because and
because these piglets eventually you
know got bigger and and he got stronger
because of it and and and he in front of
the whole Kingdom he was like look at
this magnificent specimen you know gen
you know it's this is and and of course
the vice counselor said the same thing
he said before that you know genius is
not born it is built you know through
dedication through training through
through deep work and that story that
story must very much resonate with you
you know somebody who the setbacks with
regards to learning and public speaking
and so on and so forth to now being
someone who specializes in precisely the
thing that you were the most terrified
about and if I was talking with Dan Bill
zarion last night and he the you didn't
have that on your bingo card for me
talking about I didn't and um he was
saying how
his his story you know his success
particularly with women but also in
other areas of life as well that um he
wasn't particularly funny he's 5' n he's
not particularly good-looking most of
his face is hidden by a beard uh he
wasn't particularly anything really
wasn't super smart in school like he
kind of got through the tests that he
needed to just about etc etc you know in
terms of raw materials an incredibly
like mostly average guy pretty
intelligent I guess but mostly average
guy uh with a very extraordinary outcome
and he was saying about how he feels
like the story he has at least from a a
female success perspective should be
something that other men men find
empowering or or inspiring because look
like I'm not [__] Brad Pit I'm not
6'5 I'm not like this you know super
good-look dude I didn't have I wasn't
super funny I wasn't a stand-up comedian
I didn't have any of the things you know
in terms of raw materials coming to this
and um yeah I think normal people doing
extraordinary things is is spectacular
but for the most part everybody was
normal at some point there were crazy
outliers right uh and a lot of the
things that make people outliers of the
very very hidden things their
predisposition for conscientiousness
their ability to deal with resilience
and hard times that you know those sorts
of things the kind of more like soft
hard skills I guess um but yeah man I uh
I I I always think about the journey
that people got to do something
absolutely spectacular and over the last
few years since spending time around you
know
outlier people in every different
industry they're so normal like they're
so incredibly normal and they they're
still riddled with the same you know
self-doubt and uncertainty and and lack
of esteem and all the rest of it desire
for validation almost all of them are
and you think oh well that's like an
oddly normal thing for this very
extraordinary person to have and that's
that's comforting I think like to see
that the to see that the gods are mortal
is is comforting yeah it certainly makes
it relatable you know without a doubt to
to know that these people are are flawed
uh I talk a lot about superheroes
because I mentioned I couldn't read I
taught myself how to read by reading
comic books and I don't know what it was
you know my uncle gave me a comic book
when I when I was a child and I would
just look at it and I would read these
comic books even even if the words
didn't make sense I'd be underneath the
covers you know of my of my bed with the
flashlight and something about the
illustrations really brought the story
to life and gave words the meaning and
when I started to understand the words
it was very comforting because I would
Escape you we had we didn't you know my
parents immigrated to the to the states
and we didn't have a lot of uh resources
uh we certainly education money you know
that kind of thing but um but yeah it
would allow me to escape because I was
you know being bullied in school and
that that's not fun for anyone who's
gone through that had a lot of
self-doubt but I would use it as
inspiration and these these superheroes
offered hope they offered like wow these
people are helping other people and and
they were flawed too like Spider-Man and
you know Iron Man was an alcoholic and a
lot of people had issues a lot of them
were orphaned uh
Superman uh Spider-Man Batman I mean you
just think about you know the the the
beginnings of their superhero their
origin stories they had a lot of a
tragedy and yeah it's it's a matter of
there there's a quote in Limitless that
from a French philosopher that says life
is the letter c between B and D right B
is birth D is death life C choice and
we're constantly making these choices
about who we're spending time with what
are we going to do what are we going to
eat you know where we're going to put
our Focus but also choices on what
things mean like uh the the meaning
we're associating to what's going on if
this is here to to hurt us or this is
here to prepare us and I think that
meaning as part of the mindset what it
affects what you believe is possible
what you believe you're capable of maybe
even what you believe you deserve and it
becomes this internal thermostat where a
lot of times we're acting like a
thermometer where we're just reacting to
the environment right we react to
politics react to you know Global Wars
we react to how people treat us we react
to the weather but I feel like the
people who have uh you know more agency
and you know a level of sovereignty they
feel like you know they could be a
thermostat they could they they don't
not reacting they could gauge they know
what's the temperature is but then they
also set uh they have a vision they set
some kind of standard they set a
temperature and then the environment
reacts to it you know if I if I was to
go back to that child I would the two
beliefs I would instill in the in like
my nine-year-old self would be like hey
you are 100% responsible for your life
right you can make excuses you could
complain and probably some of it is true
but so what like what's the difference
it doesn't make it doesn't change the
situation at all and it wastes a lot of
time wastes a lot of energy and and the
truth is we can't be upset you know by
the results we didn't get from the work
we didn't do and there's just a truth to
it and sometimes we're our worst
enemy you said on a podcast I listened
to recently if you fight for your
limitations you'll keep them if you
argue for your limits they're yours yeah
given that there is one of the pandemics
that didn't come from uh a virus kind of
like a a pandemic of nihilism or apathy
or at least uh limiting belief
beliefs um or believing uh what would
you say somebody has kind of got
themselves into a a routine of
despondency and externalizing of the
locus of control and not believing that
they can maybe make the progress that
they do what do you say to them to try
and drag them out of
that well for for each person uh I mean
I would want more more more contact with
that person and more more connection I
mean you're really good with social
dynamics um which is you know really
shows up in in your conversations with
people I would I would say reminding
people that they have agency is not it's
one thing to know it intellectually it's
another to like embody it right that you
know our world is a reflection of of our
choices and you know giving people
examples certainly potentially could
help getting them to e even with
children right like if somebody if a
child let's say you're trying to really
you're really strict with their diet and
they go to a birthday party and they eat
this food you know instead of like
criticizing for them just like having
them self aware realiz and just asking
them how do you feel right and what
caused that and so they can see like
cause and effect I I feel like we we all
play a role in sometimes in our own
misery and the challenge is you know
when this this the story I I I tell is
when I got to spend some time with
Stanley right the creator of so many
co-creator of so many Marvel superheroes
and we're going out to dinner and you
know I I just have this time with them
solo and I was just like hey I I'm dying
to know like who who's your favorite
superhero you all you've created
everybody right The Avengers The
Fantastic Four and so on and he looks at
me he's like Iron Man and he says Jim
who's your favorite superhero and I was
like it's got to be Spider-Man because
he had this big Spider-Man tie and uh
without a pause he goes in his iconic
voice with great power comes great
responsibility and we all know that I I
guarantee you all your listeners know
what word was coming and I I switch
words still to this day maybe because I
had a few head injuries too many head
injuries as a child when I read
sometimes I'll switch them or hear it
and I was like you know you're right
with great power comes great
responsibility and the opposite is
certainly also true with great
responsibility comes great power when we
take responsibility for something we
have great power to to make it to make
things better right with with these with
these choices that we make every single
day and so yeah I think agency is is is
very important that you are 100%
responsible and I also have this belief
that everything Marie forio has this
word everything is figureoutable right
you have agency and you could figure it
out with enough commitment and
creativity and um and I and I feel like
we grossly underestimating our own
capabilities when when I say people
fight for the limitations they get to
keep them I hear it on a regular I I'll
be on stage and before I go on people
grab me invariably and say I'm so glad
you're here can't wait to you to talk
you you're the memory expert and telling
you I'm too old and I'm just I'm just
too stupid I have a horrible memory and
that that's the context where I say hey
stop if you fight for limitations you
get to keep them you know I tell them
that your brain is this incredible
supercomputer and your selft talk is a
program it will run so if you tell
yourself I'm not good at remembering
names you won't remember the name of the
next person you meet because you program
your supercomputer not to I I I I
believe that if people truly understood
how powerful their mind is they wouldn't
say think or even feel something they
didn't want to be true and again I'll
stipulate that yes you have one negative
thought it's not going to ruin your life
obviously but just like eating that one
donut or muffins not going to ruin your
life but you if you ate dozens of that
of those donuts every day every single
day it would definitely have some kind
of effect and so I think we have to
stand guard to the doors of our mind and
and realize again that we're you know
that thoughts we don't have to believe
everything that we think and we could
also adjust what we think you know
people say I'm not smart enough or I I
don't have a great memory just you know
editing it like I don't have a great
memory yet I it just feels different it
just lands different you know and it
gives you some kind of hope to be able
to to move forward how does memory
actually work moving beyond the stories
that we tell ourselves what are the what
are the nuts and bolts of how memory
works there there are three phases to
memory there's the encoding phase there
is the storage and then there's the
retrieval phase and so if people I
believe there's no such thing as a good
or bad memory there's a trained memory
and there's an untrained memory you know
unfortunately it's not really taught in
school I mean maybe they took some kind
of class in uh in high school or maybe
college but I don't know how practical
it is you know one of the things I'm
obsessed with even when I'm listening to
podcasts or reading books it's like how
can I use this right how can I how can I
when will I use this right why must I
use this how does this relate to what I
already know I I feel like so many
people learned passively right and the
human brain I don't think it learns best
through consumption because we're
consuming all the time and so many
people's lives you know you talk about
mental masturbation so many people just
get addicted to just you know novelty
and they're just buying books and they
sit on the Shelf unread and become
shelfal not selfhelp that that whole
that whole dangerous spiral but you know
the whole idea is you learn something so
how you could apply it right if somebody
isn't consistently doing something and
they're procrastinating they're
self-sabotaging it's usually a mindset
or motivation issue but going back to
memory I'm always thinking like hey I
want to make this more sticky so how can
I encode it by not just hearing it maybe
I could see it and use more of my
nervous system maybe I could tap into
some of those feelings right you have
that middle brain uh where you have like
this seahorse looking uh part of your
brain called hippocampus uh which is
primarily function is memory attached to
it is this little almond shaped uh part
of your brain called the amydala which
is like a switching station for emotion
and it's interesting that you know the
where
uh where memory is being processed it's
also connected with emotions I think
information today it's everywhere right
so it's very forgettable it's it's not
it's very ordinary but information when
it's tied with emotion and and and
visualization becomes uh Unforgettable
right when you hear it feel it see it
then you know you're recruiting more of
your nervous system and you're more
likely to be able to to retrieve it the
storage part is interesting because we
teach people methods like a mening
filing system you know something like uh
like memory palaces you know back in the
ancient Greeks you so we we write
Limitless expanded and I pull on and
draw on you know neuronutrition and
Neuroscience and adult learning theory
uh also though ancient wisdom
you know I just feel like what did
people do before there were books what
did people do before there were like the
internet how did they remember things
before there was a printing press you
know how did they pass on history and
information you know around campfires
and one of the techniques was a storage
device uh I mean where you use locations
that you're very familiar with like
maybe your home your school your office
the mall maybe parts of your body your
car and just taking the information that
you want to remember and placing it
intelligently around those locations
because as hunter gatherers we didn't
need to memorize lots of numbers or lots
of words what we needed to remember
where things are right where the clean
water is where is the fertile soil
where's the enemy tribe all the survival
right and so even when people forget
someone's name they tend to ask
themselves questions like where where do
I know this person from right because
again the context gives you the con
content they did they've done studies
where they'll put they'll submerge
people with a breathing apparatus
underwater and give them uh things to
remember like like maybe something
simple like list of words and then
they'll take them out of the of the pool
and they'll test them and see how many
they recall very simple and then they'll
submerge them back under the water and
test them and in which environment do
you think had greater recall right it
was it was I was underwater and we we
could probably guess that but the idea
here is when you're studying something
the environment also is getting anchored
to that information and uh and helps you
to Greater retrieve it so if you like
you know we were talking about before if
you are on stage and you got the
opportunity to rehearse and practice and
review your information and study on in
that same context you're more likely to
be able to access more of that
information because unconsciously the
light the smells everything gets
anchored to the information um now
that's not possible for a lot of people
like may maybe you could prepare in the
board meeting there and then perform
there also or study in class and then
perform in class but it's not usually
the case so even something simple is
giving yourself a trigger you know I
know you've done episodes about uh
habits and and and triggers having
prompts for certain behaviors you could
bring the environment with you you could
take a certain I mean one of the most
out of the five senses smell is
definitely the one most closely
connected to human memory uh maybe for
is the most closely associated sense to
human
memory right I mean I think there's all
and maybe there's there's a reason for
that right if if you smell poison it
could be it could save your it could
save your life or food is rotten you
know you be able to recall that that's
part of your survival uh and we all have
this I'm sure there's a fragrance or
food that could take you back to when
you were a kid uh we we all have those
things and the idea here is so going
back to how the environment gets
anchored to your study um and your
recollection you could actually bring it
smell like let's say you're preparing
for your talk and you want to remember
all the different points uh when you're
live on stage you could while you're
preparing you could have a unique
cologne or essential oil or chew they
say chew gum could potentially help with
your memory but of specific flavor and
then it's but it has to be unique so
it's not diluted uh in terms of learning
and then when you want to be able to
perform use that same essential oil or
you know scented lip balm gum whatever
it is and that'll help trigger all the
information and data that you you were
rehearsing and so but the storage part
is interesting because using your body
or using your microwave like imagine
you're in your kitchen and you go
clockwise around your kitchen and say
okay you know the if I'm GNA the first
place is the microwave the second place
is the stove top the third place is the
refrigerator fourth place going around
I'm doing my kitchen is the dish washer
and then the fifth place is the sink
then that would be a way of using your
memory Palace and then you could go into
the adjacent room and do the bookshelf
and the fireplace and the coffee table
whatever and then the idea here is let's
say you need to give a tedex talk you
could take the information and turn it
into a picture because we most of us
tend to think in pictures if I ask you
to tell me about your car right well I
don't know let me do this so tell me
tell me tell me about your car it's a
BMW 123d it's like a coupe thing it's
blue uh it's got Matt Gray Alloys cream
seats amazing so when you see BMW and
blue and M you don't you don't see those
words right when you're saying it you
see you see an image of it and uh you
know our visual cortex takes up the most
real estate in in our brain which is
probably why people are better with
faces than they are with names right you
see the face but you heard the name you
you go to someone say I I remember your
face but I forgot your name you never go
to someone say the opposite you never go
to someone say I remember your name but
I forgot your face so it would make a
lot of sense there's a proverb a Chinese
proverb that says what I hear I forget
what I see I remember what I do I
understand I heard the name I forgot the
name or I heard it on the podcast I
forgot it right I saw the face you know
what you see you you you remember and
what you do going to the power of
practice right and rehearsal and study
and deep work then you really truly
understand it because I feel like you
don't you can't you don't understand
unless you could do it that just a kind
of a a principle that I and behind every
principle there's some kind of promise
and some kind of of reward and so like
let's say you wanted to give a talk in
the book I talk about how onethird of
your your your cognitive performance uh
brain health is predetermined by
genetics and biology it's pretty
accepted in the Neuroscience space but
that means 23ds is in your direct
control and I talk about the 10 levers
that would that would move that right
and so if somebody wanted to know what
those 10 things are and they had to to
give a a Ted X talk next week about it
first of all I when I want to learn
something faster I learn it with the
anticipation and the intention of
teaching it and so it doesn't matter
what I'm learning even if I'm not really
going to teach it I intend to teach it
you so when I'm reading I'm thinking how
does this relate to me when I'm
listening I'm taking better notes right
if somebody had to teach it they call it
in they call it the explanation effect
when you learn with the intention of
explaining to somebody else you're going
to learn it better because you're Focus
you're going to focus better you're
going to ask more questions you probably
take better notes and uh when you teach
it you get to learn it twice right so
like if people have that perspective as
they're listening to this conversation
like how would I teach this to somebody
else I'll you know talk about the 10
Keys maybe that move the needle science
base and think about it not just like oh
that's great information but ask
yourself how can I use this how can I
apply it uh how can I teach it to
somebody I care about right because the
number one reason to learn something is
how it would benefit you but the close
second is how it could benefit somebody
else right you learn so you can earn get
some kind of benefit to return right to
be able to share it with somebody else
and also when you share it it benefits
you also as well because you get to be
an expert at that at that subject matter
more easily so so can I go through like
some of these 10 Keys yeah dude I want
to get high level let's go through all
of them I want he them okay so so the
the first in no particular order let's
say let's start with a good brain diet
right what you eat matters especially
for your gray matter there area science
there's a whole chapter in the book on
neuronutrition that your brain is only
2% of your body mass but it requires uh
20% of the nutrients and it's an energy
hog right it uses up a a lot of energy
chess players burn some ungodly amount
of calories right like the most static
sport in history extreme extremely right
I I know a number of them that are just
always you know calorie deficient but
they're always they're always eating
without a doubt never see a fat chess
player this is true and so another
reason why you want to be mentally
engaged right we hear a lot about
physical fitness which obviously relates
also to your mental uh performance as
well and we can talk about that because
that's one of the 10 things but going
back to neuronutrition certain foods and
and I'll stipulate this with I'm not a
doctor I'm not a nutritionist but you
know and go go get a food sensitivity
test right do a nutrient profile cuz not
every is for everybody I I really do
believe everyone's bioindividual
generally though avocados the mono un
citrated fat your brain is mostly fat uh
is fatty so you know what you eat
matters again for your gray matter uh
blueberries and you know I put this on
my body so I always remember when I'm at
the store I use this as a Memory Palace
my body so I imagine uh the the avocados
using it as a a scalp conditioner like
guacamole or if I blueberries right uh
or mle berries a lot of the berries
they're brain berries they're full of
antioxidants very neuroprotective
blueberries coming out of your nose and
you know and when you're doing it you
imagine that you're a child because
children are such fast Learners uh
because they're playful and they use
their imagination that's how they
remember people's names I mean I don't
know if people made fun of your name
growing up but certainly with a last
name Quick you know I got a lot I was
the bun of a lot of lot of jokes but
that's how kids remember right they say
you know Tony Tony B like they make the
Rhymes they make it fun um yeah so
imagine you're 8 years old and blueberri
is coming out of your nose uh broccoli
is is a brain food high in vitamin k um
the sulfurane in broccoli is very good
for your brain especially if you sprout
them it tends to be like even 10 times
more sulur vean which potentially could
help with bdnf the brain derive
neurotropic factors um but imagine
broccoli stuck in your teeth so
something simple like if you want to
remember um olive oil you you know about
the Mediterranean diet um you're
cleaning your ears with olive oil or
wearing Olive earrings whatever eggs
probably one of my favorite you know
foods good protein uh the yolk is high
in in choline uh which leads to
acetylcholine which is good for
cognitive health and memory so eggs
right in your throat you're choking on a
hard-boiled egg so those are just like
you know things that I would just think
about and maybe people like kale and
spinach great make them your shoulder
pads you hear about certain fish and you
have to be careful with fish right with
the Mercury and some of the toxins but
you get a clean Source sardines like
imagine your collar you have a necklace
made out of sushi you know salmon sushi
or sardines and and and use your senses
again imagine what that would smell like
and if you can't imagine it you know
imagine you can imagine it right your
imagination what what is it Ein said
imagination is more powerful than
knowledge right knowledge is what is
imagination is what what could be right
we're recruiting more more of the those
those visual feeling you know feelings
everything and then finally um on your
fingers imagine some turmeric the kirkum
is
anti-inflammatory imagine like you can't
get this gold powder off your you know
your fingers and then walnuts we hear
all the time the vitamin E uh almonds
imagine them coming out of your belly
butt very simple and then imagine your
bottom everyone's favorite us superb
brain food dark chocolate which people
can use in their own imagination
whatever
they you mentioned there uh not just
about nutrition but the new of the book
has got some advice when it comes to
neut Tropics as yeah that's going to be
one of the uh one of the 10 things is
definitely supplementation so that that
that'll be coming up in in a few oh yeah
so just everybody imagine like your
first place imagine my my my home right
you're at the microwave and all you have
all these brain foods there and you're
taking it out and you're putting it on
your body right and and I bet you even
an hour from now one of the ways to
encode is to do space repetition right
uh and you rears it review it an hour
later and also the retrieval practice is
so very important so I mentioned it's
encoding make it emotional Mak it visual
storing we have a place to put it the
microwave right or your nose and then
the retrieval active retrieval helps
tremendously improve your memory even
something like asking your after you
read something or listen to this podcast
quizzing yourself right it sounds so
simple and common sense but common sense
is not always common common practice you
know what my favorite strategy for doing
that was for a good while I was training
uh on a morning time with a training
training partner and I would tend to
read I usually read for about 15 minutes
on the morning as part of my morning
routine and I would always try and just
explain one thing that I'd read that
morning dude I got to tell you about I I
learned this story about World War II or
I learned this story about what happened
in the space Landing or whatever
whatever and uh that was like an
absolute turbocharged hack because not
only was I doing the ret retrial thing
like memory is repeated retrieval not
repeated exposure and it was also doing
the teaching thing right so I had to
simplify it and especially given what I
do it's all about it's it's not just
having an idea of the concept it's also
being able to display it right in a way
that sounds cohesive and and sort of
slick so uh yeah yeah that was that was
a good hack for me teach a training
partner about what you've read this
morning AB absolutely and I feel like
even you know parents could do that with
their kids instead of saying how was
school and what are they going to say
good right but asking them specifically
what they what they learned and and
going m in micro and again giving them
examples again because it gets them to
actively retrieve so they have to light
up that same cognitive web and that's
really what that memory is every single
time it's reinforced and you you you
actually recreate the memory right and
so by by having that representation and
describing it it just makes it more
sticky right they say neurons that fire
together they wire together we have what
86 billion neurons and each of them have
potentiality like syap like 10,000
different connections so there more
connections you know that your brain can
make than there are stars in the known
universe right I mean this is what this
is the power that we have access to but
I feel like we we're only using a small
potentiality of it but starting with
good brain diet is is a good place to
start and then imagine that the
microwave you put it on your body and
then test yourself and teach it to
somebody else you walk over to the
second place if you're in my home and
let's say we're going to have like a
dinner together and uh we go over the
stove top and the second key that I was
talking about the 10 keys for Limitless
brain is I got this from Dr Daniel aan
the the famous uh brain doctor a
psychiatrist he's run like 40 books on
the brain change Your Brain Change Your
Life uh I he talks about killing ants is
good for the brain and ants stands for
automatic negative thoughts that's
exactly what we've been talking about
how your selft talk you know becomes
your your reality that thoughts are
things that all behavior is
belief-driven if you think you can or
think you can either way you're right
right Henry Ford said it that all the
all the self-help kind of cliches but
there's like with every cliche there's
some form and uh nugget of Truth there
so killing ants automatic negative
thoughts and while I'm going through
this people could rate themselves 0 to
10 like 0 to 10 how good is my diet
because on the other side is the
processed foods the fried foods the high
sugar foods right that's going to spike
your your glucose and so on but on scale
of 0 to 10 kind of rate yourself because
everyone to know like what's the one
thing you know everyone wants like the
magic pill but there's not there's a
process of these 10 things so the second
one's killing ants so just imagine on
the stove we're roasting ants we're
killing ants right uh and so that's very
simple you can't forget it takes more
time to certainly describe it than it
does to picture it and a picture is
worth a thousand words so there's a lot
of descriptives there and then walk over
to the third place which is the uh in my
case happens to be refrigerator and this
is exercise right we know that um
especially strength training right it's
been she saying strength training right
it it's it's for so many so many
benefits right uh bdnf which we talked
about brain deriv neurotropic factors
which is like fertilizer for the brain
helps support neuroplasticity
neurogenesis uh neurotransmitters you
think about the dopamine the serotonin
the endorphins that that you get from
from working out uh potentially systemic
uh decrease in inflammation uh it helps
also with insulin resistance I so many
benefits from from physically working
out and I don't just mean that but when
you're rating yourself 0 to 10 is moving
throughout the day you know we're
talking about if we're talking about
evolutionary science the brain the
primary reason we have a brain is to
control our movement you know and as
your body moves your brain grooves so
it's not just a mindbody connection
there's certainly a body mind connection
and you that's one of the we we have a
10-month old right and he's learning how
to crawl but they say crawling for
children is so important because it
stimulates different parts of their
brain brain even the act of learning how
to juggle there's a study done at Oxford
University that jugglers actually have
bigger brains they by the act of
learning how to juggle you could uh
actually create more white matter and
this could be something simple like
where you're rolling up socks and just
doing it over a table or a bed making it
very simple watching a YouTube video
starting with one then moving graduating
to two and three I'm not talking about
like you know flaming swords or or or
electric saws or anything like that but
you know 0 to 10 how much are we moving
so imagine you're open the refrigerator
and you were doing your favorite
exercise inside that your personal
trainer is there you're doing your
whatever your soul cycle your your
burpees your your CrossFit whatever but
it's in the refrigerator all right and
that's to remind you of exercise the
fourth one is what you're alluding to
let's go over to the fourth place which
for me again is the dishwasher and those
are your your nutrients your brain
nutrients I would always prefer people
get it from
from their diet that now that's my
personal preference and again who am I
to give you know like people I think
ultimately we're talking about agency
that people should really you know test
it themselves right you you could trust
but then you you validate and test with
your own personal experience um I would
always prefer people get it from food
but if they're not eating eggs then
maybe they could they could supplement
with choline right it's a Nutri nutrient
found in foods like eggs and soybeans
and it plays vital role in in in brain
health right an acetylcholine which is a
neurotransmitter um and you could
harness that that that power right some
people want to supplement they're not
getting it from the the fish maybe they
want to supplement uh omega-3 fatty
acids particularly uh DHA right which is
crucial for for brain health it's it's a
primary it's a it's a structural
component of the brain and it plays a
key role in memory it plays a key role
in in brain function um I don't know you
are you a big supplement guy yeah I work
with a company called Marik Health um
and they're they're really great for
blood work and and they've got me sort
of vertically integrated into a whole
bunch of stuff based on my system uh
omega3 Esther uh I've been taking which
are like pharmag grade uh Omega 3s uh we
actually have this this isn't out yet
but by the time that this episode
happens it will so this is a drink that
I've been working on with a friend for
over 12 months now and that is half a
gram of cognizin which is a branded cyto
Coline it's a version of Al Alpha GPC
Roda Raa which is stress induced fatigue
reduction panex Gins sang Natural
caffeine no sugar uh Aline B vitamins
all of that stuff and um I did four
episodes in 27 hours in La last weekend
wow dude the only way that I was able to
get through that was uh adrenaline and
the right amount of this and I think
that I think is definitely a place for
acute performance enhancers for mental
cognition because how many like what am
I going to do increase my egg
consumption for two weeks in the buildup
to that so I'm oh yeah my cyto Coline
response is really great because I've 30
eggs a day for the last two weeks or
something and um I'll get your address
once we're done I'll send you some cases
of this I think you really enjoy it and
um yeah I I'm a I'm a big fan of it I've
been playing around with New Tropics for
a long time uh I found some stuff here
an anti- neut Tropic actually I got put
on an anti- energic about two years ago
just like a normal very boring thing
from the doctor but dude it was like um
someone had just half the ram that I had
in my brain I couldn't remember the name
of places my thoughts felt sluggish uh
and I'm very very tuned into the texture
of my mind right like the nimbleness of
same with you I'm sure the nimbleness of
my thoughts my ability especially for
recall and then not just recall but all
of the little nuances and I'm telling
the story and I have to remember to
pause here and so on and so forth and
dude it was it was just like walking
through mud or something it was a I
can't I can't see you in that state
because you're so good at tracking even
when some of the conversations you've
had with uh mutual people that we know
like Alex like like maybe loses place
and you pick it up exactly where where
where they leave I did it at dinner I
did it at dinner the other night we were
talking about something and someone left
some Loop open and uh I was like it was
10 minutes later and I really it was
some story about a cat and I really
wanted to know about this cat and I was
like Dude tell me about the cat he was
like oh yeah you're in podcast mode and
I was like I just want to know about
this [__] story about the cat but um
no yeah you're right it's um it's very
scary to have uh it was almost like
having um a cute temporary dementia yeah
uh and it was dude I absolutely do not
wish that on anyone so yes make sure
that you get your choline Foods in make
sure that you get your col energic
system working nicely uh you know Alpha
GPC is a fantastic solution cognizin
which is in this in neonic is an
activated version of that which is great
um around about around about half a gram
a day seems to be the effective dose
that's been pretty well studied um so
yeah I thinking with that is a good
place to start yeah the one the ones I
was talking about were more brain
supplements um I separate that from neut
Tropics in the book but the the choline
supplementation the the the dhas your B
vitamins right especially vitamin uh B6
uh B9 folate 12 is vital for brain
health magnesium is vital for everything
right every every physiological function
learning especially for your brain
learning memory uh certainly for for
your mood uh some people supplement with
that uh in different forms of it um uh
like L3 andate you know for for various
things for rest glycinate glycinate I've
been playing around with I can't
remember I can't remember the brand it's
this huge big white tub that marck sent
it's like fat thing but yeah sleep my
sleep latency improved uh an awful lot
since since taking since taking that so
yeah all the simple stuff seems to be
the ones that work and that that's what
I look for like even right now I'm
drinking some green tea so it has the
you know alanine which is an amino acid
that's that's found in green tea it's
it's you know obviously very popular and
atropic it also promotes relaxation
without the the drowsiness and enhances
brain function uh you mentioned bopa you
know which is an herb Artic medicine uh
which can improve cognition and and
memory um riola you mentioned also which
is Scandinavian herb um which has been
shown to help uh reduce mental fatigue
and improve it's going extinct you know
that it's going extinct at the moment I
did not we're having a we're having a
nightmare so the formulation for this
that we spent ages putting together to
be evidence back research based all the
rest of it uh and we decided to put
something in which is like a protected
speci so the price of it it's just gone
through the roof but would it would be
really cool I would love to um do like a
regenerative uh thing with the drink
where you know for every one plant that
we use we plant two more type um that
would be cool but uh I'm a huge fan the
Roda thing um this amazing study that
was done on nurses so they gave for 28
days they gave uh efficacious dose of
Roda which is the same one we've got in
there to nurses uh working in the
National Health Service in the UK they
found that they made fewer commiss
errors under stress and it's what's
technically referred to in the
literature as a reduction in stress
induced fatigue and um it just for me
made a really big difference because
your ability to stay on task and to stay
focused is we said it at the very
beginning like context often is a primer
ahead of everything else and if the
context that you're in is I am stressed
I can't deal with this this is getting
to me Etc Etc no matter how much your
prep done like you've just got this huge
ceiling that comes down on top of it
okay so I think where we're in your
dishwasher at the moment yeah so we're
putting all these supplements there you
could put the uh one probably one of my
favorite ones is
creatine well you know you know
obviously people a lot of people
Associated to to to working out it's
it's found you know in higher levels in
meat and in fish but it plays a huge
role in energy metabolism especially for
uh improving cognitive function you know
especially tasks that require uh
short-term memory and so uh that's and
you know and everything else that we
talked about that were in the foods like
the turmeric the kumin right you get
supplement with that uh you know some
people make uh if I'm if I make if I
don't do the tea sometimes I'll have
some kind of lines main mushroom you
know which is potential neur neurotropic
uh protective effects uh which is uh
this maybe it has been shown to be able
to stimulate the synthesis of a nerve
growth factor which could enhance
cognition and potentially even lower uh
inflammation uh caffeine obviously a
powerful one especially if you add it
with the Eline so for me I don't it I
could get the energy without the the
Jitters I'm very very sensitive some
people like Kinko also for for blood
flow um we actually put all this uh
we're going to actually take the what's
in the book and people could go to a
brain nutrition.com and see kind of the
where what I get you know and the ones
that are human studies
both for supplementation and also the
nrop but that I would put all those
bottles of supplements in the dishwasher
all right and then that's number four
number five is uh we're we're at the snc
and what I believe is very important
that we' talked a lot about on our
podcast is the social networks having a
positive pure group has been shown to be
good for your brain because who we've
heard this a million times right who you
spend time with is who you become or the
average of five people we spend the most
time with if you're on 9 broke people be
careful because you're going to probably
be number 10 we have these things called
Marin neurons where we're just we're
always imitating people around us
unconsciously usually and I always tell
people to watch you know the things
we're marring and imitating are usually
the W and watch are words where we tend
to have the same language pattern same
slang as the people that that we spend
time with the A and watch is are the
actions the behaviors because it has lot
less to do like if you smoke has less to
do with your biological networks or your
neurological networks and more your
social networks if your friends smoke
that's definitely more of an influence
to you than your biology uh and then the
t is our thoughts we tend to have the
same recurring thoughts as the people
around us C is character we tend to
maintain the same level of uh character
integrity uh and you know moral uh
standards of the people around us and
then finally the H and watch our habits
right you've heard this phrase where
first you create your habits and your
habits create you and uh you know we
talk a lot about morning routines and
evening routines uh I've enjoyed a lot
of the things that you've talked about
about it also as well so all positive
peer group is so important we all need
people to encourage us to challenge us
to call us on our stuff uh to cheer lead
for us and if you haven't found that
person be that person right it's also an
opportunity to have someone to teach to
right not everyone has a substack or a a
podcast or a YouTube channel where
they're teaching random people on the
internet but you have the opportunity to
be around people who are curious and who
are going to about new things like dude
some of the conversations I've had in
between sets in the gym have been some
of the best things that I've ever done
my housemate literally has a podcast
called the lift companion where he goes
and trains in the gym and the podcast is
about what happens in between the sets
and uh it's it's it's awesome it's
really really fun and you realize that
you know you have this really lovely uh
periodized all right we're going to talk
for a moment you know 60 seconds 90
seconds during the rest period Then
someone's going to train
then the other person's going to train
and then we're going to come back to it
and we're going to do another 90 seconds
it's this really lovely Rhythm actually
to talking about something I very much
enjoy it and uh any any excuse to go
into the gym more and excuse it as
learning absolutely and there's certain
brain types that we talk about in the
new book these are cognitive types it's
an assessment that I put together I've
been using test I did the test oh good
good good yeah we could we could we
could talk about that a few minutes
after that these 10 things but like
elephants are highly empathetic and they
love that specially uh the the community
they love uh collaboration they they're
the ones that keep everyone together and
they have high levels of empathy so they
would really you know those are
wonderful people to have in your life
also as well because sometimes learning
is not solo it's social for sure you
know book clubs and having
accountability Partners or workout you
know buddies all all that's really
important but just imagine your positive
peer group at the uh the sink and we're
all just like washing dishes or
something like that and that's that
helps you to Anchor it so then when
you're giving your Ted Talk you could go
through and just walk to the microwave
and you're like oh all the brain foods
right and you can probably some of the
people listening if they weren't
multitasking when they're listening they
probably remember that their avocados
and blueberries and broccoli and olive
oil and eggs and so on all over their
body and then on the stove top you're
killing roasting ants and then you open
up the refrigerator and people know that
there's movement and exercise uh as your
body moves your brain grooves you go to
the the the dishwasher and you have all
your inotropics there and then they at
the sink and your positive peer group
and then you walk into the other room
we'll do the rest really fast super fast
so that we get close the loop you know I
know you you talked about the zaric
effect and this psychologist uh whose
last name happens to be zyg garnic and
she's at a cafe The Story Goes where she
sees everyone all the weight staff uh
deliver the orders and take everyone's
order and not write any of it down and
which is pretty magnificent uh because I
love it when someone does that wait up
and he's got his hands behind his back
it's almost a flex they know what
they're doing oh yeah oh yeah and and
and I I'm still as much as I know about
memory I'm just like oh please write
this down just because we'll mess this
up and have to wait again but the zaric
effect is basically they they will
retain that order until they are
delivered because the brain doesn't like
open Loops right and you know Netflix
and all these binge shows they're really
good at keeping open Loops to keep
people coming back right and uh but yeah
we want to close this slop for everybody
so they're not like raging on YouTube
and stuff now number six so go into my
second room and the first the sixth
place is going clockwise is the sliding
glass door and so I just want you to
remember the six key is a clean
environment clean environment uh we find
that your external world is a reflection
of your internal world and you know you
clean your desk or make your bed or
maybe you're on your computer and
everything's the right folder you tend
to have Clarity of thought um and when I
say say clean environment also going
back to like you know when you ingested
that uh that toxin that kind of threw
you off there are a lot of neurotoxins
in our environment it could be off
gasing from furniture or from your
carpet and so you know having clean air
is important whether you you you have
the windows open uh or you have an air
purifier uh I would include clean
environment even the light sources right
so many offices and schools they use the
like fluorescent lights and that's
probably not you know your eyes are only
part of your brain uh that that's
outside of your skull right and when you
have visual fatigue it leads to mental
fatigue and uh and they they probably
fill offices and schools with that
because it's Ultra cheap also also also
as well but clean environment so from
the lighting from the water from the air
and also just organize you know recondo
your mind so you get zero to 10 kind of
rate yourself how clean your environment
is now some people say messy
environments is good for katos but
that's probably is true because it stim
ulates yeah think about think about it
this way like walking into any artist's
studio what have you got there's a torn
up novel over the far side and cigarette
ends and there's a magazine and there
you know that's not the environment in
which you want to do your tax return
your tax return is in the office next
door it's nice and clean it's clinical
it's sterile focused but you also don't
want to try and do your next ideation in
this room that's bereft of any
inspiration for you yeah absolutely so
and and also like keeping track of where
everything is could also be some Undo
You Know memory or Ram that you're doing
just consciously keep track of
everything right it's a lot easier to
put your keys in the same spot every
single time so you don't have to kind of
think about it going back to storage
right encoding storage and then you
could retrieve it because it's always in
the same storage place so you have a
mental a physical file folder not an
actual file folder but a place that you
store it in also also as well and you
you've talked about this like regulating
certain activities for where you thrive
like you're not going to work in your
bed because you're going to get that
angs in your executive functioning and
wonder why later on you can't sleep
there right because of all all that
state is being the emotional state is
and that activity is being anchored to
the environment like we talked about
submerging underwater it's not just the
information it's the feelings that are
being anchored and so like even
something simple like if you use your
iPad to to watch Netflix and that's your
entertainment system don't don't do work
on it right I mean something something
simple like that I really struggle to
read on my phone for that reason you
know there's a great uh tool called send
to Kindle for Google Chrome and it's
just a just an extension it's an Amazon
Like official application and you press
one button and the web page becomes
fully optimized for Kindle and delivers
to your device if you got paper white or
an oasis or something and uh it turns
your Kindle into a rater app but the
alternative for me was to use try and
use pocket or something which or like a
uh I can't remember that other one
everyone uses and and like I'm going to
read it on my phone I'm like no I'm just
if I'm on my phone I'm in task switching
messaging executive function mode if I'm
on my uh Kindle all I'm thinking about
is ah like if I bet if I tra on my whoop
I bet that as soon as I pick my Kindle
up I just get parasympathetic activation
100% that happens that the device that's
in my hands primes the way that I feel
with without a doubt you for for me
I read most of mine on you know print
it's just my I'm looking for any
opportunity to not be on a screen but
without a doubt our devices get anchored
the same way as our our our environment
so yeah I would say number six think
about the the the door is just clean
environment so just imagine we're just
cleaning the glass and we're just
cleaning the environment around the door
which happens to be the sixth place the
seventh place is the radiator so I have
a radiator there and I would just say
the seventh key is sleep so just imagine
you're sleeping on the radiator and that
that would be very uncomfortable right
you feel the heat and um but sleep
obviously for your brain is so very
important it's probably the number one
thing uh it's something that I struggle
with for a long time I have uh I was I
had undiagnosed obstructive sleep apnea
severe where I sto breathing 250 times a
night and I was only sleeping a couple
hours a night for five straight years
and doctors didn't know how or why and
had this because misdiagnosed for
something else and I eventually had his
surgery I had UCLA where they took out
my uela soft pallet tonsils it was very
painful to Great more air flow my sleep
jumped up to like four hours but it it'
be like 250 times a night is a lot
because each time counts as 10 seconds
so that's what an episode was so it's
like the doctor was saying no wonder
you're not sleeping it's like somebody
coming in and put a pillow over your
face a couple hundred times a night and
so I had a lot of you know anxiety
around it I Ed CPAP and dental devices
and all these things but you know
optimizing your sleep because
specifically for your brain because when
you get a when you don't get a good
night's sleep how are you performing the
next day how's your ability to solve
problems how's your focus how's your
mental endurance right how's your memory
you know when you sleep you consolidate
short to longterm memory if you have
long-term memory issues maybe do a sleep
study yourself you could get it easily
done at home you know most doctors could
prescribe that um it's also where you
cleat out the you know the sewage system
kicks on in your brain that can Lally uh
you know because if it's not taken care
of it could lead to brain aging
challenges I lost my grandma mother to
alzheimer's when I had my two years
after I had my brain injury when I was
five so that's why I'm just very
passionate about about brain health and
and my inspiration really is my
desperation but we've heard all the
Great Brain hacks there's a whole
chapter in in here on how to optimize
your sleep um we've done many episodes
on it my favorite ones and I know your
audience knows this but I just want to
say maybe say it in a different way just
to remind them because are they doing it
right if because I know sleep is a big
or sleep loss is a big challenge um
direct sunlight first thing in the
morning right to reset your circadium
rhythms um caffeine I can't do past 2:00
in the afternoon because at the halflife
I'm extremely sensitive to caffeine so I
just want to kind of kind of pull that
back a little bit um and then just
realize that your brain loves a schedule
everyone has an alarm to wake up I
really would have alarm to trigger you
phasing to sleep otherwise it becomes
11:00 12:00 at night and you know we're
not prioritizing our sleep but your
brain loves a schedule even on the on
the weekends and then as hunter
gatherers we would going back to like
you know why we are the way we are we
would know it' be time to sleep because
our environment would tell us there be
dip in two environmental factors
temperature and light right so the
colder now where it's so cold your
you're it's it's distracting keeping you
up you're shivering but also uh you know
darker and sometimes we want to get off
those devices also because they can
mimic uh it could fool your mind into
think it's still daylight right say uh I
I read this a couple of week weeks ago
which is just a nice again pneumonics
and memes and easy ways to remember
stuff the 321 rule of 3 hours before you
go to bed no no more food 2 hours before
you go to bed no more liquids 1 hour
before you go to bed no more devices the
most difficult one embarrassingly is the
1 hour before bed no more devices
because we're so we're so like
acculturated to using them that you
think what am I going to do for that
hour before I go to bed if I'm not using
my devices and it's actually a pretty
good question but um certainly for me I
find uh if I sleep uh if I eat close to
going to bed my sleep is wildly
disrupted uh whoop did this is a really
cool thing that they do they aggregate
anonymously all of the user data and
they look at correlations in journal
entries but and they know right they
know what people say that they did and
they actually can read the data on the
back end and um eating close to bedtime
was one of the biggest uh alcohol and
eating close to bedtime were two of the
biggest uh disruptors when I to sleep
that that's been my personal experience
also if I if I eat I'm not I can't go to
bed you know and so if I end up
finishing a meal because I'm out with
clients or something at 9 o'clock then
I'm pretty much screwed because I'm not
going to bed till at least midnight also
and alcohol certainly could could have
that effect also as well working out
sometimes before you go to bed you know
because you want to bring your heart
rate down but I but I will go into a
sauna in the evening because or a hot
bath especially like an Epson salt cuz
the Magnesium helps you to be able to
relax cuz you're absorbing a trans deral
um also when you leave the sauna or you
leave the the hot bath your core body
temperature drops right which is a
signal to produce melatonin same thing
with the lighting you know but now with
modern
conveniences we don't have to have it
drop in temperature or light right so we
have to take agency again and and make
conscious decisions uh for for our sleep
hygiene so that that that's uh and also
dreaming also I I talk about how to
remember your dreams in a lot of you
know like in the book and other things
you could do because it's remarkable in
that REM state where you do a lot of
your brain doesn't shut off at night
I'll just offer this as inspiration uh
and a lot of in Inventions uh works of
art literature CA music came from dream
states you know they say that Mary shell
created Frankenstein in Her Dream a
chemist created the framework of a
perodic the perodic table in his dream
Paul McCartney came up the song
Yesterday in in a dream right and just
lots of lot of stories Elias how created
the sewing machine in his dream like
these kind of things but that that pre
supposes you're getting good sleep right
because not just the quantity of sleep
it's the quality of your your slow brain
wave like the deep sleep and the REM
sleep um so yeah that sleeping on the
radiator uh so just imagine that
everyone remembers it then you walk over
next uh we have a china cabinet and
there you want to be able to remember a
brain protection uh protect your brain
this is a simple one right your brain is
very resilient but it's also very
fragile having had you know three head
injuries before age 12 and I had this
you know I had my brain brain scann and
did all these hyperbaric chambers and
and just kind of getting blood flow in
the areas that were damaged um just
imagine you're headbutting the the china
cabinet with a helmet and the helmet
reminds you to protect your brain and
then finally um we have uh like a a
couch kind of area here and U and on the
couch you can remember the next thing
which is new learnings so just imagine
you and I I'm talking to the listeners
here on that couch and we maybe have a
whiteboard and we're just putting the
words new learnings in your favorite
color right because it's so important
just as you keep your the way you build
your body right is through novelty and
nutrition and then sleep right but same
thing with your mental muscles right it
it requires novelty and nutrition and it
can even potentially help you to age
better meaning there was a study done
with nuns and they wanted to find out
there a longevity study they living 80
90 uh and above and researchers wanted
to find out what was the you know the
contributing factors half of it had to
do with their emotional faith and
gratitude I'm summarizing this the other
half they were lifelong Learners they're
always reading having debates
conversations and they're suggesting
because of it it add years to their life
and Life to their years they they put
this study on the cover of Time Magazine
it was called Aging with Grace you know
but on a scale of 0 10 and everyone
who's listening has a 10 right out of 10
because they're always learning um that
would be key because that that's really
where the novelty the newness right you
make new connections um can be very
supportive and then so imagine that on
the couch we're doing new learnings and
then finally the the dining table there
um let's say the last one is Stress
Management all right we talked about
stress and coping with stress so
whatever you do we talked about how
chronic stress you know could have
negative effects on the brain maybe it's
body work on the dining table you know
or you're meditating on the dining room
table and just take a moment and just
picture that so the idea here using the
storage we started this with encoding
storing retrieving is we've encoded it
using visualization and feelings and
story we've stored it in very specific
places on our body or you know in my two
rooms of of my home and then now can you
retrieve it so now you're on stage and
you're going and you see the microwave
and I'm talking to people really who are
listening at home what does that
microwave remind you of right what's
coming out of the microwave and what are
you putting on your body all these brain
foods and you're probably remember it
from avocados all the way to to dark
chocolate and backwards because when you
understand how your memory works so you
can work your memory and you go over the
stove top and you're killing ants right
you open up the refrigerator and I'm
just kind of making this interactive the
exercising and then you have your your
uh your dishwasher and it's filled with
those brain nutrients right the neut
tropics and then who's washing the
dishes all your positive friends and
then you go in the other room the
sliding glass door your cleaning it
because you're cleaning your environment
then the radiator what are you doing on
it the behavior is you're sleeping right
remind you of sleep and then you go over
the china cabinet putting on a helmet to
remind you brain protection and then you
look at the couch what are we doing
we're learning always be learning and
then finally the dining table getting
massage you're meditating managing your
stress so it's just kind of a fun and
takes way longer to describe it but I I
would challenge people to do their own
home and then they can put when you're
having a conversation with someone
you're doing an interview with somebody
maybe you're not taking notes but you're
taking mental notes and you're putting
some of the key points that you want to
remember in places either on your body
or office and and it's really infinite
it is Limitless the amount of places if
you see card counters do that or people
like if you see me memorize 100 words or
what like these are this is a solid
strategy to be of facts figures uh
presentations and and so so much more I
had a card counter actually Steven
Bridges British guy who has a huge
YouTube channel uh that people should go
and check out it's really cool uh and he
goes and takes on casinos on tours like
literally like that movie 21 and there's
a big player and there's the counters
and there's the Spotter and all this
stuff wild and uh yeah he he was just
like I'm just a normal guy I was into
maths and magic and then realized that
with a bit of training and a bit of work
on my memory that I could keep a hold of
the count and I can make I can take
casinos for you know 150 or 250 Grand
over the space of a weekend which is not
yeah not not a bad earner traditional
carard counting is like math right so
they they have a A plus if you went
through it on your pocket right plus one
minus one zero each card has Mount so
that you kind of know the probability of
a of a 10 coming up and you can make
your bets accordingly but how they
communicated in 21 with their with their
their partners that were undercover at
the table is they would use signals and
they would use an alpha numeric code
where every number has a sound and this
is like a a code where like they're 10
digits and there also 10 consonant
sounds in the English language and each
one is is has something so if they
happen to be you know up 15 for example
or or in this case they they use
something different they used basic
Association so they said like hey if it
happens to be like uh like happens to be
a six up and that was about the card
counting six could be represented by
like a a gun like a six shooter right
they use that in the conversation and
then people would know like the the
exact number they were doing um they
have nonverbal signals as well uh
because didn't want to keep on saying
the same thing in case Mike's Mike's now
using AI pick up on the things that
they're saying and they can flag that in
the back end so yeah it's a a permanent
war of evolution between the card
counters and the casinos yeah and this
could be a disclaimer also this is for
recreational purposes only for listeners
it's not legal it's not card counting is
not legal according to Steven uh in the
united St in certain places in the
United States um one of the things that
I think might be useful I'm thinking
about the use case of what we've gone
through through so far um great in terms
of optimizing our minds you know we
mentioned at the beginning that people
have got an awful lot of information
that they're either indexing consuming
in one form or another one of the things
that I wish someone had taught me before
I started the show uh was about that
Discerning skill that we mentioned
previously and I one of the ones that
I've used which I think is really great
and almost alleviates pretty much all of
the stress uh there are certainly things
that you have to learn right if you're
going to go and be a a doctor
um you need to learn all of the things
in this and you're going to be testing
on all of the things and if you're going
to learn to drive a forklift truck or
whatever it is right like there are
certain things where you have to learn
the entire body of work but for
recreational learning or for stuff that
you're going to use to improve your life
Tim Ferris has an idea called the good
[__] sticks and what he means by that is
we
often castigate ourselves for not
remembering things that we weren't
interested in Remembering simply because
we have this sort of arbit
uh sense that I should remember all of
the stuff that I listen to or I should
remember most of the stuff that I listen
to but really your job as you listen to
podcasts like this or read books or
substack articles or whatever it might
be your job is to discern what are the
elements of this that are specifically
applicable to me and even that as a
decision trait it's like is you know we
can get all up in our head about should
I be using that am I ever going to want
to try and learn to juggle maybe I
should buy more socks so that I can do
the it's like ultimately the thing that
you listen to on a podcast episode or
reading a book or or whatever that you
can't not take a photo or a screen
recording of you can't not you can't
stop thinking about it that's the good
[__] right and with that okay let's go
narrow and deep on that on that one
particular thing and we can use all of
the tools that we've spoken about today
to try and help really embed that but
when it comes to the Discerning side of
stuff massive overload of information
how is it that I'm going to choose
what's useful to me for me it's like a
it's the most embodied and natural way
of doing it there's no decision tree
there's no nothing I'll just be
listening to some Morgan hell told me
this story yesterday about the guy that
was choosing the the working out how
fast people could run I was like I I
can't not remember that right like I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure I tried to
explain it last night and failed uh
after I'd spoken to him so all right
that's the thing I don't know why that's
the thing but that's super important to
me so I'm just going to use that so yeah
from a Discerning perspective I think
the good [__] sticks really lovely
simple rule I I I like it primarily our
brain is more of a deletion device
nowadays we're trying to keep
information out because if we let I mean
what there's probably a billion stimuli
that in our environment or things that
we could be thinking that we could focus
on and so for me it's a reductive
process it's it's eliminating because
you know keeping the most important
thing is to keep the most important
thing the most important thing right and
so I think questions are the answer in a
lot of these cases you have a part of
your brain called the reticular
activating system Ras which determines
what we're going to shine as a spotlight
on you know so you could use that
analogy if you're reading a page in a
book getting to the end and forgetting
what you just read I guarantee you you
don't have adequate questions that
you're obsessed about because then if
you did you'd be shining a spotlight say
there's an answer there's an answer
there's an answer right and uh and we
have about 60,000 thoughts a day and a
lot of those thoughts come in the form
of questions and then and questions some
people suggest is is part of the act of
of thinking you're asking and answering
questions of yourself you know questions
like what's the best use of this of this
moment or you know you're mentioning you
know with with Tim like how do I how do
we make this easy right or how do we
make this more more enjoyable or what's
the lead Domino right these questions or
how do I reach my 10-year goal in six
months right where you can't just force
it and just work harder you have to you
know think think differently and so you
know I think three questions again that
I I obsess about when I'm listening to a
podcast or reading something is things
like uh how can I use this right and and
I'll actually extrapolate and say like
okay this could be useful and then
that's my filtering system because I was
like oh I can't really use this and I'll
just kind of set it aside this is not
important for me you know I don't even
note take that way you know I'll put a
line down the page and on the left side
I'll take notes this how you read faster
learn languages whatever I remember
people's names the kind of stuff that
that we teach in the book but then
if my mind wanders that that right brain
imagination wanders it wanders on the
right side of the page and I'm capturing
like how does this relate to what I
already know right what questions do I
have about this how am I going to use it
why must I use it right what's a real
cool feature for the uh Kindle obsessors
amongst us if you use highlights um
there's actually a bit where you can
highlight and then add a note and you
just use the uh the little crappy keypad
on the screen um but just a tiny little
bit of cont text is great do you use
readwise do you know what that
is I I don't I know what it is yes okay
yeah well just when it resurfaces the
highlights from Kindle it also adds the
notes in yeah uh so you're not just
resurfacing that one particular
highlight it also reminds you of the
link of the thing that you made so it's
like networks of information are being
sent back towards you I think that's
that's uh that's cool I like it yeah I
mean I love digital because it's I mean
when people are handwriting not it's
been shown to help comprehension and
retention but certainly digital notating
is a wonderful way to store information
share information and integrated in in
other things also as well yeah yeah one
of the things that's still outstanding I
think from the tool set that we've
spoken about so far is concentration and
focus I think a lot of people have a
very negative relationship with their
ability to stay focused on task so
what do you usually look to First what
are the big movers the 820s of uh of
focus and attention it depends the
context and the behavior of where like
when people come to me and say they want
a better memory I I hear like somebody
coming to a coach and saying I want to
be better at sports I'm like well what
sport specifically because there's
different methodologies and strategies
and tools depending on on their goals uh
same thing with Focus if people are
losing focus when they read there could
be a number of contributing factors one
of them is what we mentioned they don't
have enough questions so they're not
getting those answers but another it
could be if they're reading and they're
losing focus their mind wanders they get
the easily distracted it could be
they're reading too slow right you have
this incredible brain and you feet this
super computer brain when you're reading
one word
at time metaphorically we're like
starving our mind and if you don't give
your brain the stimulus and craves and
needs it'll seek entertainment elsewhere
in the form of distraction so sometimes
it's you actually don't have the focus
because you're reading too slow because
it's like driving slow if you're going
really slow in your neighborhood you're
not really focused on the active driving
right you're you're thinking about
something that you have to do that day
you're drinking your coffee you might be
texting whatever you could be five
different things when you're going slow
but if you're racing cars and taking
hairpin turns as fast as you could go
you're not thinking about the dry
cleaning or you're not trying to text
you're completely focused on two things
what's in front of you and the actual
Act of driving right and that's the
equivalent of I found with reading we
have an online Academy it's the largest
online accelerated learning uh Academy
in the world we have students in every
country so we have a lot of data right
and we find actually that in general the
faster readers actually have better
comprehension because they have better
focus and so U speed equals focus focus
equals comprehension and comprehension
gives you the retention so I would
challenge people that they're learning
maybe processing too slow and if youve
sped it up a little bit you you won't
have time to distract yourself and focus
on other things and you'd be monotasking
as opposed to trying to trying to
multitask and the other part of focus
would be on your brain type and I know
you took the quiz this is something I've
been using with with coaching clients
for for years and I realize just how the
like there's personalized medicine based
on like your genetics or personalized
nutrition based on maybe your microbiome
there's also we created a personalized
learning based on your brain type and I
realized and I I I created this model
and it's a Model A framework right uh to
be useful and and and explain our way
our Behavior and the results we're
getting and also the behaviors and
results of the people around us so just
the quick of it is I I I I pulled
inspiration from like personality types
like Myers bricks introvert extrovert uh
multiple intelligence theory uh learning
styles verbal uh audio kinesthetic uh
lateral dominance like left brain right
brain anyway so it's code c o d and
these are I use animals because everyone
wants to take like a quiz and what Game
of Thrones character am I or what I
don't know Harry Potter School that kind
of thing so it's kind of fun I don't
know it maybe take four minutes did it
like something like that yeah I did it
on my phone yeah it's it's free there's
nothing to buy and so we we offering
this out to the world because what it's
not how smart you are it's how are you
smart right and this determines this
gives you shines a light on how you are
smart so code is an of course for the
animals the cheetah are your fast actors
right they they they Implement really
really fast they they're uh they're they
have strong intuition uh they uh they
love to adapt right uh the owls are
you're they love logic they're very
analytical methodical they Thrive when
given a space to dissect to ponder
Ponder to to analyze things these are
individuals who benefit from uh deep
work sessions right away from from
distractions you have your Dolphins the
D in code and these are your creative
Visionaries they have strong pattern
recognition uh some uh entrepreneurs
they're Visionary thinkers they can
maybe see a future or an innovation when
other people can't quite see it yet uh
so these are your creatives these are
your dreamers right and then finally the
E are your elephants and your elephants
I mentioned earlier are your empaths
these uh they're very empathetic they're
High collaborative souls and they they
are the glue that holds like teams
together and just to give people a
visual take anything in popular culture
i it doesn't matter like I don't know if
you have a favorite show or uh you know
movie that we could draw on whether it's
Star Wars or James Bond or Harry Potter
or friends like if you take friends like
you see the archetypes everywhere so
like if you watch Friends Ross would be
an owl right he's a scientist he's very
astute he studies research right you
would say that someone like Joey would
be the cheetah very instinctual just
just acts right um You would say uh
Phoebe is the creative dolphin right
with with her music and her art and and
uh you know her the the visions and
Imagination that she has maybe Monica
would be the elephant right brings
everyone together always wants to host
all all the parties and so on but you'll
see this in everything you know James
Bond J James Bond would be the cheetah
right M uh who runs MI6 would be the owl
very very very logical methodical uh
money Penny her right hand you know we'd
be more the uh the elephant Q who makes
all the inventions would be the creative
you know Visionary so you could go
through and you could do Harry Potter
you could do any of this but also it
informs the careers like I had our team
which we have a few dozen people around
the world uh it's remarkable 100% of our
customer service team were elephants
because they found they found their
elements right they're there to be loyal
and supportive and empathetic and have
your back ta right because their success
you know is your success and your
success is their success you know our
financial person our CFO is is an owl
right our our our CEO she's a she's a
creative Visionary she has this you know
positively impact one billion brains
right um and has very you know
imaginative things of using that so it's
it's interesting when you understand
your brain type because it also can
inform your your learning and so when
people take the quiz it's um we created
I think you we sent you a mybrain
animal.com corre my brain animal and it
takes 4 minutes and you can send it to
your spouse and it'll explain their
behavior and so you don't have to get
like judgmental and everything because
that's just how they think and this is
how they learn and this is also
correlated to how they you know even
communicate with people and so it's it's
it's a kind of a fun way to kind of get
to know each other and and stuff because
the cheetah tends to be more direct
right straight to the point and the
speech is very concise and I know and
now you could you could overlap other
commun communication and influence
models over this right to give it make
it even more Rich you know because you
I'm sure you have distinctions that that
I don't have on this but um you know
cheetah is very concise focus on action
all the very action oriented words
they're very instinctive they trust
their gut they have strong intuition
they speak in a way that's uh very
independent owls are are analytical
methodical and think about it an owl
would invest different than a cheetah
they would buy different than a cheetah
they would be influenced they would date
you know different they would
communicate right owls would be a little
bit more patient there like like
yourself uh like you're you're like you
you do so much research right you are
willing to listen you pause you reflect
before speaking right these are owl
traits I don't um you know I'm not sure
what I read the PDF the PDF was cool
because it was talking about um you know
it's nice to be told what you are or a
description that makes you feel seen or
makes your whatever disposition feel
like less of a just weird personal curse
but it's also interesting because it
says things like here are some of the
areas that you might want to look out
for here are some of your uh potential
weaknesses this is the way that you can
communicate better with uh the elephants
in the room and the cheaters in the room
and so on and so forth and uh yeah it's
cool dude I I think the the the quiz was
great the PDF that you guys give
afterward also uh really cool so people
should go and check that out and you've
got new book will be out now when this
episode drops as well newly revised
version there it is I didn't get it
what's happening I didn't get that I I
got a digital version send me that
version we're we're gonna send this to
you along with along with the t-shirt we
got your back I'm fully quick pilled
once I get yes I I can't I can't wait
the Expanded Edition was updated with
all new case studies from previous
readers and it also is all about
momentum so we added chapters in there
you know once you unlimit your mindset
your motivation and the methods of speed
reading memory you know all the stuff
Focus getting in flow habits all the
stuff we could you know discuss offline
we talk about momentum how to create
greater momentum in your life and we do
it through understanding your brain type
right so I put all the research and
examples in there the quizz is also in
the book uh because that knowing
yourself will help you to you know have
less friction in your life and relate
with others and influence others better
we also have the entropic section in
there uh which uh people could enjoy
because that could actually more
momentum talk about learning agility
like in a post-pandemic
world uh from you know whether you're
working hybrid or remote or in person uh
there's a whole large chapter on AI too
how to use AI to enhance your a hi and
for me hi is your human intelligence
right and it's not artificial
intelligence for me it's really about
augmenting your intelligence and
different ways you could use it to
accelerate your own learning and earning
in life but yeah Limitless book.com
thank thank you so much I I've been
looking forward to this and I want to
thank you for the work that you do were
can I ask which animal you you tested it
I okay that's what I was saying because
even with the questioning you ask
probing questions get clarity and often
you know you could play Devil's Advocate
and you could test an idea's validity
like I I just it's and you're very
structured you know the way the way you
you speak and I I I try to follow you
when I'm listening when I'm working out
and everything and I kind of like I I
love the pace and Cadence and and the
way you you you make ideas you know very
sticky and relevant in people but yeah
it's been a it's been a wonderful
pleasure we have to have you on our
podcast too I'm down get me on oneone
you need Jim and uh I really appreciate
the kind words I've been a massive fan
of your work for a long time everyone
you're going check out your book they
can go and do the brain quiz and uh yeah
dude I'm excited to see what you do next
it seems like there's always always more
desire for people to improve their brain
function I don't think it could come at
a better time than right now so keep
doing what you're doing thank you can I
challenge everyone to do one quick thing
absolutely uh take a screenshot of this
remember I said that you know knowledge
is not only is potential power P we use
when we take a small simple step and
something that everyone could do right
now yes you could obviously go to do the
brain quiz and stuff like that but take
a screenshot wherever you're con
assuming this listening to it or
watching it and tag Chris tag myself we
get to see it and just share either your
brain animal or one thing you're going
to do for a better brain we went through
at least 10 different science based
things that you could focus on maybe
it's reading a little bit more adding
these brain foods these neut Tropics
that Chris has or something you know
prioritizing your sleep add that in the
post and that way and tag us so we get
to see it and I I'll actually repost
some of my favorites and gift a few
copies out to the community just as a
thank you and reinforcing
that uh knowledge times action is power
you know I truly believe that there's a
version of yourself that's patiently
waiting and the goal is we show up every
single day until we're introduced so
it's an honor to be on this journey with
all of you hell yeah Jim quick ladies
and gentlemen Jim I really appreciate
you thank you if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe